I really want to be able to live in a world where technology is like oxygen.
It's obviously vitally important and it's ubiquitous, it's everywhere.
But you don't ever see it.
And you don't ever think about it.
It's just there, and it works, and it helps you.
I hate when it starts to affect my social relationships...
...and my interactions with people.
I'm all for living a digitally connected lifestyle,...
...provided I'm given the option to turn down my level of connectedness...
...at certain points in the day.
That means giving myself breaks from my smartphone or my computer screen...
...when I'm trying to be creative or when I need to de-stress,...
...and when I really want to concentrate at the task or the person at hand.
Our solution was to create a line of designer jewelry that subtly vibrates...
...only when something important happens on your phone.
Our smartphone app allows you to predefine profiles.
And then within each profile,...
...you can select which notifications pass through the filter...
...and make the jewelry vibrate.
I definitely think there's possibilities...
...that allow us to do kind of many amazing things.
So, now I think this is just the beginning.